Okay, so today I'm gonna be going over the whole prenup question
slash comment I get on my page a lot.
And this is kind of related to the backup question and why I don't, um,
really promote a backup here on my channel,
but mainly in my personal marriage.
Um, if you.
Whatever you guys do in your marriage,
go for it.
But today I'm gonna be talking about why I do not have a prenup
or any sort of,
I guess you could say,
backup plan aside from life insurance.
I am a big advocate for that.
But anyways, we're gonna get into that in this video.
So I'm just gonna say this right off the bat.
I trust my husband.
I know. Shocker. Shocker, right?
Yes. That's the man I chose to marry.
I got to know him very well.
I know my husband's character inside and out,
and I trust him
to the point where
I would have never asked my husband
for a prenup before we got married.
In fact, I'm pretty sure he would have taken that kind of as an insult,
um, that I don't trust him,
and I'm not confident in my decision to marry him.
In fact, I think prenups make divorce nicer, in a way.
So these couples get together, and they prepare for the worst.
They don't want the worst.
Nobody gets married just to get married.
I think most people get married for love.
Um, but when people Put prenups together.
They are thinking,
well, if worse comes to worse,
let's at least make this worse outcome better for both of us.
I don't see the point in making divorce
better and more desirable in any way whatsoever.
Therefore, I don't promote, um,
prenups on my channel.
Um, I don't know if that's crazy to you guys.
As I've said before,
I do believe life insurance is very wise for couples to get.
Whether you are in a traditional marriage or a more modern
fifty fifty marriage,
life insurance does prepare
both the husband and the wife for the worst case scenario.
Another comment I see regarding this whole just in case backup idea
is from other traditional wives,
and they say that they will actually store money,
like, hide money away from their husband just in case,
like grocery money or whatever it might be.
And I think that is completely wrong.
I don't think women should be hiding money away from their husbands.
That's deceitful.
Do not plant the seeds of deceit in your marriage at any point in time,
because those sprouts will grow.
And hiding money away from your husband as a just in case,
in my head, that's kind of like you are investing in your own divorce,
the destruction of your marriage.
Um, I don't want to think about that.
I don't, um,
entertain those thoughts in my head.
In fact, my husband and I actually have a funny rule in our Um, marriage.
We don't use the D word,
which is divorce.
Like, we won't talk about it.
We've had this agreement. It.
We just pretend it doesn't exist.
But we live in a culture that divorce is very normal.
A lot of people my age,
I'm 26, have divorced parents.
Both my husband and I have divorced parents.
And we live in this culture where it's so normalized.
But personally,
this is just my opinion.
With my marriage,
I would never, ever,
ever think about divorce.
I would do what it takes to stay with my husband.
And I know my husband is the exact same way.
This is one of the negative outcomes from social media,
in my opinion.
We are watching millions of people live millions of different lives
with millions of different outcomes,
and it is scaring people into thinking,
like, all these crazy scenarios.
Do you know how many people wish that I will get hit by my husband
or that I get divorced and cheated on?
I get these comments on a daily basis.
And you wanna know something?
I pray for my marriage every single day.
My husband prays for a marriage every single day.
I pray for my husband individually,
just like I pray for myself individually,
and my husband does the same.
The power of prayer is real.
It protects you with the blood of Jesus Christ.
The enemy wants to ruin your marriage.
Protect your marriage with prayer.